ja die aktuelle Energiekrise ist zu 100%
ausgemacht wenn heute Rentner ihre
Stromrechnung nicht bezahlen können wenn
Betriebe vor dem ausstehen dann hat es
vor allem einen Grund das ist eine eine
Fehlentscheidung in der Vergangenheit
das ist der Atomausstieg
die
Kernkraftwerke die wir haben zählen zu
den besten der Welt und trotzdem könnten
sie trotzdem haben wir hunderte
Milliarden in wetterabhängige
Energieformen investiert die nur
funktionieren wenn russisches Gas den
Backup dafür macht in den in den
dunkelflauten jetzt fehlt dieses
russische Gas und die Energieversorgung
ist teurer und unzuverlässiger als
jemals zuvor wenn jetzt auch noch die
letzten drei Kernkraftwerke wegfallen
wird Energie noch knapper und damit noch
teurer und ob das die deutsche
Wirtschaft überlebt das ist hier die
große Frage das werden wir sehen
eine Laufzeitverlängerung von fünf bis
sechs Kernkraftwerken hätte
eine sehr stark mildernde Wirkung auf
die Energiekrise wir würden ein Zehntel
der co2-mission einsparen wir könnten
ungefähr den Strompreis um ein Drittel
absenken wer die Rechnung nicht glaubt
ich habe sie veröffentlicht in einem
Fachjournal und andere Ökonomen haben
das auch im Wesentlichen bestätigt
und unsere kernkraftwerke sind noch so
gut technisch dass sie noch
jahrzehntelang preisgünstig zuverlässig
und sicher Strom erzeugen können und
emissionsfrei vor allem Brennstoff
könnte für den nächsten Winter leicht
beschafft werden das dauert ein halbes
Jahr dann steht er auf dem Hof die
Menschen die Mitarbeiter die sind jetzt
noch da oder können aus der Frührente
zurückgeholt werden also was fehlt ist
eine einfache Mehrheit im Bundestag und
weil die Grünen sich in diese Frage so
unbelehrbar Verhalten kommt es auf die
FDP und die beiden großen Volksparteien
an und im Übrigen hätten die auch eine
große Mehrheit der deutschen Bevölkerung
hinter sich deswegen mein Appell an die
Bundestagsabgeordneten handeln Sie
verantwortlich für die Menschen für die
Wirtschaft und vor allem für die Umwelt
geben Sie den deutschen die es wirklich
verdient haben das Beste was Sie
bekommen können nämlich unsere deutschen
Kernkraftwerke auf Dauer zurück
jetzt könnte man auch argumentieren und
das tun einige wir schaffen das auch mit
alternativen Energien wir schaffen das
wenn wir auf Wind und auf Sonne setzen
Harvey hat jetzt gerade das zweite LNG
Terminal an den Start gebracht die
Preise sinken sogar wieder der Winter
ist mild alle spielt uns in die Karten
ist doch alles nicht so schlimm ja aber
genau das ist es ja also habe ich hat
vor allem Braunkohlekraftwerke
Steinkohlekraftwerke und Gaskraftwerke
hochgefahren alles nur um diese Klippe
nicht nehmen zu müssen
atomlaufzeit Verlängerung aber immerhin
Unabhängigkeit vom russischen Gas das
ist wunderbar aber schauen Sie mal auch
zu welchen Kosten und es ist einfach
empirisch kann man das sehen überall auf
der Welt wo man versucht vom CO2 in der
Energieversorgung runterzukommen gibt es
Ende zwei eigentlich zwei Typen von
Ländern die einen machen das mit
Wasserkraft und Kernkraft und die haben
sehr niedrige Energiekosten und die
anderen machen das mit wetterabhängigen
Kraftwerken und mit ganz viel weg gehabt
das und das heißt man muss zwei
Energieversorgungssysteme aufbauen und
dann wird es eben auch doppelt so teuer
der Faktor 2 stimmt sogar auch ungefähr
Zara du darfst Reinecke ich sehe schon
dass du auf heißen Kohlen hast es in dem
Zusammenhang auch noch sehr gut quasi
sitzt greift gerne eine die Diskussion
ja also wir leben gerade in einer Zeit
aufgrund der Energiekrise wegen des
Ukraine Kriegs wo weltweit sich etwas
ändert in Sachen Atomenergie wohl
wirklich eine Trendwende weltweit
erleben international Japan ist aus
eigentlich aus der Atomkraft
ausgestiegen jetzt steigen sie wieder
ein Italien Niederlande Belgien
Frankreich Polen wahrscheinlich noch was
vergessen die konzentrieren sich jetzt
alle auf die Atomkraft und das ist ein
ganz wichtige Energiequelle jetzt für
die und Deutschland macht mal wieder den
German Alleingang ich habe auch das
Gefühl es ist so eine Kombination aus
Partei Ideologie der Grünen und diese
German Angst sich der Atomkraft
hinzuwenden und ich finde es wirklich
nur noch absurd dass die Grünen alles
dafür geben würden um einfach nicht
irgendein Atomkraftwerk anzuschalten und
wir haben auch eine ganz andere
Situation in Deutschland
mit den Atomkraftwerken die viel
sicherer sind als zum Beispiel eine
Frankreich die runtergewirtschaftet sind
und trotzdem tauchen immer wieder solche
falschen Argumente auch auf hat der ist
sie leben auch im Libanon ist das
richtig wie blickt man derzeit gerade
auf Deutschland ist das eigentlich noch
der große Big Player in irgendeiner Art
und Weise oder wundert man sich auch ein
bisschen wie die Deutschen einige Themen
angehen ja im Leben und eigentlich also
gibt es eine riesen Energiekrise es gibt
Strom nur zwei Stunden am Tag und
trotzdem
man redet dort nicht so heftig über die
Energie und Energiekrise wie in
Deutschland das ist tatsächlich so hat
etwas mit German Angst zu tun ich habe
auch früher in Japan gelebt und da kamen
dann diese Atomkatastrophe in Fukushima
in Deutschland hat man sofort den Atom
auch Ausstieg entschieden quasi ohne
Parlament und in Japan hat man nur
darüber Debatten geführt wie können wir
Atomkraftwerke
sicherer machen in der Zukunft und das
ist entscheidend Fortschritt und Angst
können nicht zusammen gehen man braucht
für den Fortschritt tatsächlich
Zuversicht und Rationalität und nicht
dass man die Themen emotional behandelt
wie das Thema
klimawandelt glauben sie wir sind bei
vielen Themen zu emotional absolut wo
zeigt sich das bei welchen Themen sind
wir Deutschen ist die Politik vielleicht
auch sind wir alle zu emotional du musst
mehr Ruhe Pragmatik das mit der Ruhe ist
ja ganz was zentrales wir sind überall
dort sehr emotional wo wir abgetrennt
sind von großen Ganzen ich sag das jetzt
ganz einfach so wo wir abgetrennt sind
von von den Bewusstsein dass wir eine
Menschheit sind dass wir einen Planet
sind das auf diesem einen Planeten noch
andere Zusammenhänge sind zu anderen
Planeten dass wir uns abgetrennt haben
von der Natur und da gibt es eben
natürlich auch die Gegenbewegung die
sind aber nicht so laut ja diejenigen
die ganz klar jetzt ich meine jetzt
nicht die Klima Kleber sondern ganz
viele Menschen die sich wirklich mit
Spiritualität beschäftigen das sind ganz
gewaltiger Trend ich bekomme ich bin ja
mittendrin ich bekomme das sehr stark
mit und diese Emotionalität das braucht
Führung es braucht ein Bewusstsein sich
eben aus einer Ruhe heraus zu bewegen
man kann sehr gut und sehr klar
diskutieren da sind wir dabei Respekt ja
man kann wie auch hier super Runde
Meinungen sagen und miteinander dann
auch ins ins Gespräch kommen aber wenn
wir emotional ins Gespräch gehen dann
gehen wir von der Frequenz hier in einen
näheren Bereich und der macht nie Spaß
und der macht sehr viel kaputt und
schlussendlich auch krank oder auch tot
deswegen es ist jetzt in diesem Übergang
in dem wir sind zu lernen auch durch die
vielen Emotionen die da sind nicht nur
in uns Menschen oder in einzelnen
Berufsgruppen sondern weltweit dass wir
lernen mit dem was uns ausmacht was uns
wirklich ausmacht nämlich der Blick zum
Universum der Blick zur Ganzheit als
Menschheit als ganze Zeit dass wir nicht
einzelne Segmente sagen dass jetzt der
Staat für sich und der Stadt für sich
sondern die ganzheitliche schau die wir
immer wichtiger also das auch alle
zusammen gehören das ähnelt auch ihrem
Appell Herr Dr Peters eben gerade als
sie gesagt haben die FDP die
Volksparteien die müssen jetzt mal
versuchen zusammenzuhalten und alle
gemeinsam die Grünen mit ins Boot zu
holen und so ihre Meinung die AKWs zu
verlängern vielleicht sogar auch neue zu
bauen was glauben Sie wie viel Erfolg
wird das haben glauben sie dass ihr
Traum wenn ich das jetzt mal so
formulieren darf Wirklichkeit wird also
ich bin ziemlich im Austausch mit
einigen Bundestagsabgeordneten ähm ich
das die Frage beschäftigt mit mich
natürlich auch sehr ich glaube dass die
die FDP höchstens ein Führungsproblem
hat also eigentlich außer Christian
Lindner sind eigentlich alle wirklich
sehr stark ausgeprägt für eine
Laufzeitverlängerung sie wissen auch sie
brauchen nicht wirklich beim Wähler
anzutreten wenn sie das nicht hinkriegen
und wenn sie die Wirtschaft runterfahren
deswegen das ist also
das ist die die das Selbstverständnis
einer Wirtschaftspartei das darf die
nicht machen
bei der CDU die tastet sich sehr mutlos
an das Thema ran weil sie eben noch eine
klimaunion im Nacken hat das sind
eigentlich grüne die wo man nicht ganz
versteht warum die in der CDU sind ich
habe es noch nicht verstanden aber der
das behinderte Diskussion im Inneren
deswegen schreiben diese mutlose
Anträge im Bundestag wir wollen für zwei
Jahre die die Kernkraftwerke noch
erhalten die Energiekrise wird noch 10
Jahre dauern solange werden wir die
Kernkraftwerke wirklich brauchen
mindestens und bei der SPD gibt es ein
bisschen ein paar Leute im eher
gewerkschafts-bereich die natürlich auch
wissen ihre industriearbeite verlieren
ihre Arbeitsplätze und damit sind die
wahrscheinlich auch als Wähler weg wenn
die nicht in die pushen kommen und jetzt
wirklich was machen und deswegen also da
ist ein ein bisschen Rest Hoffnung habe
ich aber jetzt nicht da
letztlich ist es irrelevant weil die
ganze Welt Kollegen
riffler hat gesagt die ganze Welt baut
Atomkraftwerke wir werden jetzt auch ein
Jahrzehnt der Innovation sehen im
Bereich der Kernkraft
es wird eine globale Renaissance der
Kernkraft geben zu es wird eine
verhundertfachung der Anzahl der
Kernreaktoren geben weltweit und ob
Deutschland ein bisschen gleich dabei
ist oder erst in 20 Jahren wenn die
Wirtschaft mehr oder weniger schon
runtergefahren ist früher oder später
kommen die früher oder später da kann er
spät für einige zu spät sein also lassen
Sie uns auch einmal das Szenario
besprechen was passiert wenn wir auf den
Zug nicht aufspringen was glauben Sie
was passiert dann gut wir werden jetzt
ähm das sehr teure LG dann weiterhin
brauchen sehr häufig wenn die
Kernkraftwerke fehlen werden die auch in
der in der in der Mary oder wenn sie
sehr oft Preis setzen sein für den
Strommarkt die Stromkosten werden sich
permanent auf 150 € rund plus minus dann
50 jeweils einpendeln früher waren die
zwischen 30 und 50 ist also eine
Vervielfachung und eine ganze Reihe von
30 bis 30 bis 50 Euro pro Megawattstunde
an der an der Strombörse also drei bis
fünf Sense pro Kilowattstunden
Produktionskosten jetzt sind wir bei
eher so bei 15 Cents und das bedeutet
für ganz viele Unternehmen die
energieintensiv produzieren die
im internationalen Wettbewerb stehen
dass die ganz ganz großen Standort
Nachteil haben und es findet ihr heute
schon statt bASF hat gesagt sie werden
es werden in den USA nach China gehen
weiter große Firmen die wir hier
brauchen die abwandern ganz genau und
wie viele Jahre kann das gut gehen bis
ich in Deutschland für uns alle
Arbeitsplätze Wirtschaft bis das
wirklich spürbar wird das Problem ist
also erstens es wird jetzt schon spürbar
die Lieferketten sind gestört das hat
viel mit Corona zu tun aber es hat auch
tatsächlich viel mit dem also
Düngemittel fehlen Ammoniak fehlt das
sind alles eben sehr dieser
energieintensive Produkte die oder die
mit Erdgas hergestellt werden das ist
nicht witzig also das kann auch sehr
schnell zu einem Zusammenbruch führen
wenn wenn ein paar Firmen das reicht ja
mit 5% der wichtigsten firmenausfallen
dass dann die anderen keine Produkte
mehr haben mit denen sie produzieren
können und das ist die das das ist das
was es so gefährlich macht jetzt mit der
Energiepolitik so rumzuspielen und so
fahrlässig solche Entscheidungen zu
treffen dass man die Kernkraft nicht
weiter anfasst und und auslaufen lassen
möchte